all right hearing from folks all over
the country and World via our Discord
server which you can find at
davidpackman.com
slash Discord let's talk briefly to
Stavros from Greece we've never had a
caller from Greece before Stavros
Stavros please unmute so that we can
hear you it would be a pleasure how are
you
uh fine thank you good um I was
wondering like say Trump disappears from
Politics as you have predicted may
happen yeah do you think any drunk
children like I don't know Don Jr or
Ivanka maybe will try to revive the
Trump brand of say politics for a
potential 2024 run something like that I
think it's plausible but I think there
will be something intermediate there are
rumors that maybe Lara Trump Eric's wife
will run for Senate in North Carolina
that's a possibility and I think that
would be for 2022 there's the idea maybe
of Ivanka or someone running for
something short of President so you you
may actually see that before you see one
of the kids try to run for president and
we you know we sort of have to see how
the next two years shake out remember
Stavros they also could be tied up in an
illegal investigations for the next two
or three years and it might interfere
with their ability to run for anything I
I just have no idea what the next couple
of years look like for that family
yeah and you don't see them maybe like
joining the mainstream Republican party
and mainstream ideas they sort of have I
mean that see that's the thing the Trump
cultists
are sort of at odds with the mainstream
Republican party but for the most part
while Trump has done his public scandals
the Republicans have just kept doing
what they'd be doing anyway passing tax
cuts for the rich appointing right-wing
judges and justices so the the Trump uh
kids and the Trump Family itself has
mostly bowed down to the Republican
Party except for cases in which they
don't get along like on stealing the
election as an example but I I think
that we just have to wait and see
yes of course um okay thank you very
much my pleasure start with now what
part of Greece are you in
uh Athens Athens I've never been but I
would love to go uh soon I don't know
whenever it's safe you know
yeah it's very nice you should you
should come and is it uh is it the type
of City where you can kind of get around
easily on your own as a first-time
visitor
I mean you can it's not we don't have
the best you could say public transport
system okay
uh it I think it's doable and what's the
weather like right now in December
I mean it's called Uh cold for you know
brick weather
um I think it's kind of like California
in general the climate here so when you
say cold how many degrees are we talking
about
I don't know probably 10 degrees Celsius
oh my goodness that sounds beautiful
that sounds delightful
yeah it's nice yeah
I hope to hear from you again my friend
okay thank you all right Stavros from
Greece very strong